pourquoi voulez-vous être un lobby boy
qui ne serait pas
au grand budapest monsieur
et ainsi ma vie a commencé junior lobby boy en
formation sous le strict commandement de mr
gustav h
beaucoup des clients les plus appréciés et les plus distingués de l'hôtel
sont venus pour lui j'aime
toi je t'aime elle était de la dynamite dans le
sac au fait qu'elle avait 84 ans. j'ai eu
plus vieux c'est aussi quand j'ai rencontré agatha
elle est charmante elle est tellement charmante est-ce qu'il
flirte avec toi oui
j'approuve cette union je suis devenu son
élève et  il devait être mon conseiller et mon
tuteur
la police est là pour
leur dire que j'arrive tout de suite
elle a été assassinée et tu penses que je l'ai
fait
hé
tu as l'air si bien chéri tu es
vraiment je ne sais pas quel genre de
crème ils  je t'ai mis à la
morgue mais j'en
veux c'est la dernière volonté de madame dee et le
testament de mr gustaf h une
peinture léguée connue sous le nom de garçon avec pomme wow
quoi
qui est gustav h j'ai peur que ce soit moi
donny si je t'apprends jamais une fois  posé un doigt
sur le corps de ma mère vivant ou mort je vais
à b  ed avec tous mes amis,
nous devons faire un plan pour votre survie
cachez ceci c'est dans le code et vous aurez peut-être
besoin d'une loupe pour le lire mais
il vous dit exactement où et comment
trouver un garçon avec une pomme je suis un boulanger je suis  pas
une clôture si c'est le terme
je veux des barrages routiers à chaque jonction sur
50 kilomètres je veux des barrages ferroviaires à
chaque gare sur 100 kilomètres
entrer
je veux 50 hommes et 10 limiers prêts
en cinq minutes
vous ne pouvez pas l'arrêter simplement parce qu'il est
un  Immigrant sanglant,
enlevez vos mains de mon garçon de lobby,
avez-vous déjà été interrogé par les
autorités, oui, à une occasion,
j'ai été arrêté et torturé par la
milice rebelle après le soulèvement du désert,
vous connaissez bien l'exercice, puis zip
vous